[Musique]
la tour eiffel c'est un des monuments
les plus emblématiques de paris que
dis-je de paris de la france et même du
monde mais qui auraient l'idée de vendre
la tour eiffel qui bâille un escroc qui
a eu cette idée là
[Musique]
nous sommes au début du xxème siècle un
homme un tchèque du nom de victor le
sting commence une carrière d'escrocs il
parle cinq langues et effet des petits
larcins ici à gauche à droite et décide
de partir aux etats-unis et là il va
escroqué un certain al que pond way le
parrain de la mafia lui extorque 5000
dollars ce qui est une fortune à
l'époque pour atur de pau ce faire avoir
par le cap horn et avoir des
représailles y part de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
et il arrive à paris il profite de la
vie sauf qu'en 1925 et lit dans un
journal que la tour eiffel coûte
extrêmement cher au gouvernement
français et le journaliste conclut son
article en disant que peut-être que le
gouvernement devrait vendre la tour
eiffel c'était une blague mais et victor
le style lui va se dire ah il ya quelque
chose à faire ici ils vont ensuite se
faire passer pour un fonctionnaire de
l'état et il va convoquer au produit
certains des plus grands industriels
dont un certain andré poisson ouais bien
nommé maintenant il faut faire et le
poisson comme on dit le stig voulu faire
croire qu'on veut vendre la tour eiffel
bien sûr pour utiliser le métal pour
faire ce qu'on veut avec et poissons vos
erreurs quelle bonne idée et il va même
payé un pot-de-vin à le stig y va se
faire avoir et l'on dit mais ça y est ça
va être révélé au grand jour peau du
tout il ne dit rien il vaut carrément
noyer le poisson comme on dit
le site va donc en profiter pour vendre
la tour eiffel une deuxième fois mais là
il va se faire avoir rival en prison il
va sortir et va bien sûr continuer sa
carrière d'escrocs parce que visiblement
avoir vendu la tour eiffel deux fois ne
lui aura pas suffi